making a movie is a collaborative effort
but at the end of the day the director
is the one who's calling the shots and
sometimes they get things very wrong in
fact at some of the greatest filmmakers
in history cringe when they remember
certain moments from their own movies
here's a look at some scenes at
directors regret shooting at all camryn
rewrites history Titanic is one of the
most popular films and movie history but
not everyone is a fan thanks to some
artistic liberties taken by writer
director James Cameron regarding the
story of the ship's first officer
William McMaster Murdoch a real
historical figure who lost his life in
the tragic sinking of the Titanic some
theorize that Murdoch may have committed
suicide though there's no proof at all
Cameron decided to rumba there even
adding a bit where Murdoch shoots
another character first Cameron
explained to National Geographic I took
the liberty of showing Murdoch's shoot
somebody and then shoots himself we
don't know he did that but you know the
storyteller and me says oh I start
connecting the dots he was on Tootsie
he's carrying all this burden with him
made him an interesting character
residents of Murdoch's hometown
protested the scene a Murdoch's nephew
worried the film would ruin his
ancestors name Cameron ended up
apologizing saying I wasn't thinking
about being a historian and I think I
wasn't as sensitive about the fact that
his family his survivors might feel
offended by that and they were Googlers
tragic Odyssey you think when it comes
to Black Panther Ryan Coogler wouldn't
have any regrets it's the most
critically acclaimed film on the MCU
it's the ninth highest grossing film of
all time and it was genuinely a landmark
moment in the history of superhero
movies still koogler told the Toronto
Sun he regrets getting rid of the
villainous ulysses klaw played with
verve by Andy Serkis I like claw I was
bugged by having to do that it's tough
when you have to kill characters off and
I really did love that character I love
Andy he's a lovely person but again it's
one of those things where when you've
got so many people in a movie some of
them have to go Abraham's needs a hug
after the shocking death of Han Solo in
Star Wars our force awakens fans are in
desperate need of a hug and so
presumably was Hans life partner too
Bukka yet when he arrived back at the
rebel base general Leia just walked by
him to offer solace to Rey a total
stranger in
seen that bugged a lot of people
including director JJ Abrams who said he
regrets the optics of the situation
he told slash film it looks a lot worse
than it was as Chuy was preoccupied with
getting the injured Fenn some medical
attention anyway had Chewbacca not been
where he was you probably wouldn't have
thought of it but because he was right
there passed by Leia FL almost like a
slight which was definitely not the
intention
Gluck insults Zeno Tom Cruise may be the
face of Scientology but Hollywood is
filled of plenty of other adherents
including actress Jenna Elfman
unfortunately while attending the first
screening of a 2011 film Friends of
benefits
Elfman was blindsided by a Scientology
joke which hadn't appeared in the script
and nobody had warned her about it and
if any of these cameras are hooked up to
the actual Scientology center that was
an inappropriate joke and I apologize I
believe in the freedom of science
fiction director will clerk told
indieWIRE he regretted how the joke
played out the way I work I changed the
script a lot ball was shooting R yell
out try this try that we shot the joke
once and then we left it in but I feel
really bad because I didn't tell Jenna
about it and then I forgot whoops
Gluck triggers a reaction after the
Scientology Fiasco you think director
Will Gluck would have learned his lesson
but in the 2018 film Peter Rabbit
Gluck incited an uproar thanks to a
scene with her supposedly cute rabbits
intentionally trigger a nearly fatal
allergic reaction in domhnall gleeson
'he's character by attacking him with
blackberries the scene led to major
backlash online and Asthma and Allergy
Foundation of America even weighed in
condemning the sequence for making light
of such a serious issue in a children's
film as a result Gluck and sony picture
formally apologized saying that they
were very very sorry